VIRGINIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
CANDIDATE, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> JON: PRESIDENT BIDEN HELD A
NEWS CONFERENCE IN ROME TODAY
AFTER THE G-20 SUMMIT WRAPPED
UP.
HE TOOK QUITE A FEW REPORTER
QUESTIONS AND COVERED A RANGE OF
TOPICS FROM GLOBAL MINIMUM
CORPORATE TAX TO VARIOUS CLIMATE
CHANGE INITIATIVES.
PETER DOOCY HAS A RECAP OF THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS.
PETER?
>> JON, THE PRESIDENT ONLY TOOK
FIVE QUESTIONS, UNFORTUNATELY,
WE WERE NOT ON THE LIST THE
STAFF HANDED HIM, BUT I CAUGHT
HIM ON THE WAY TO THE MOTORCADE
TO ASK ABOUT NEW REPORTING IN
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL" ABOUT
POSSIBLE CASH PAYMENTS TO
MIGRANTS WHO WERE SEPARATED FROM
FAMILY MEMBERS DURING THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION.
>> PRESIDENT, IS IT TRUE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE $450,000 TO
BORDER CROSSERS, WHO WERE
SEPARATED?
IT LOOKED LIKE HE HEARD ME, NO
ANSWER, AND IT IS POSSIBLE HE'S
JUST NOT FAMILIAR WITH THESE
REPORTS.
THE PRESIDENT IS CELEBRATING
TAKING ONE BIG STEP TOWARDS ONE
BIG TAX HIKE ELABORATING ON WHY
HE AND HIS FOREIGN COUNTERPARTS
ALL AGREED TO GO BACK HOME AND
PUSH FOR A GLOBAL MINIMUM TAX AT
15%.
RIGHT NOW IT IS 0%.
NOT HIGH ENOUGH FOR THE
TRAVELING PRESIDENT.
>> INSTEAD OF NATIONS COMPETING
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER TO TRACK
INVESTMENTS BY BOTTOMING OUT,
CORPORATE TAX RATES, THIS SET OF
A MINIMUM FLOOR OF 15% TO ENSURE
THE GIANT CORPORATIONS BEGIN TO
PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE NO MATTER
WHERE THEY ARE HEADQUARTERED
INSTEAD OF HIDING, HIDING
PROFITS OVERSEAS.
>> THE PRESIDENT ADMITTED TODAY
THE G-20 COUNTRIES WHO CAME HERE
TO ITALY, REPRESENTING 80% OF
THE WORLD'S GDP DIDN'T GO AS FAR
AS THEY COULD HAVE IN COMBATTING
CLIMATE CHANGE BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T GET TWO OF THE BIGGEST
POLLUTERS ON THE BOARD, SINCE
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO COME.
>> DISAPPOINTMENT RELATES TO THE
FACT THAT RUSSIA AND -- AND --
AND INCLUDING NOT ONLY RUSSIA
BUT CHINA BASICALLY DIDN'T SHOW
UP, IN TERMS OF ANY COMMITMENTS
TO DEAL WITH CLIMATE CHANGE, AND
THERE'S A REASON WHY PEOPLE
SHOULD BE DISAPPOINTED IN THAT.
I FOUND IT DISAPPOINTING MYSELF.
>> SO THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
TRY HARDER AT A CLIMATE-FOCUSED
SUMMIT FOR THE NEXT TWO DAYS IN
SCOTLAND.
THAT IS A WRAP FROM ROME.
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING ALL THIS
WITHOUT HIS PRESS SECRETARY.
WE FOUND OUT IN THE LAST FEW
MINUTES JEN PSAKI HAS TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID-19.
SHE SAYS SHE HAS NOT BEEN IN
CLOSE CONTACT WITH THE PRESIDENT
SINCE LAST TUESDAY.
AND THEY WERE OUTDOORS MASKED
THEN.
JON?
>> JON: BETTER LUCK NEXT TIME
GETTING YOUR QUESTIONS ANSWERED.
PETER DOOCY FROM ROME.
PETER, THANK YOU